[Music]
welcome to vm end to end a show where we
have a vm skeptic and a vm enthusiast
try and hash out our vm still amazing
and awesome uh so brian thanks for
coming in today i appreciate you happy
to be here let's get to it yes yes last
time we talked about uh are cloud vms
relevant you know are vms still relevant
in a cloud native future you said
definitively yes so today i want to go a
little bit deeper and and find out what
exactly is a cloud vm can you help me
out absolutely let's get into it and you
know first it's it's a virtual machine
you know like i think most of what
people know about virtual machines is
all true for cloud vms and the the thing
i hope we get out of this today is that
there's a bunch of extra stuff you might
not know about or might not think to
look into okay so let's all right it's
like a cloud v it's like a regular vm
but not so a regular vm we said it's a
it's a machine on a computer you said
cloud vm is a little bit different
what are the specific differences with
the the real parts the physical parts
yeah in the end it's all running on real
computers somewhere right so you know
when the vm is up and running you've got
a real cpu you've got real memory um
and
i think the
the parts that are the most fluid are
probably the disk and the network um and
you know in google cloud those are both
software-defined
services that give you a lot of
flexibility
so i think the the takeaway here is
instead of thinking about it as a slice
of one computer think about it as like
the slice of a data center's worth of
computers wow all right so that's an
interesting thought to me and and what
i'm curious about is if i have a slice
of a data center how is that manageable
or usable like if i wanted to make a
video game what do i do with a slice of
a data center i think that's a great
example so it's down to you know what
are you trying to do and we then take
you know a bunch of the variables that
are possible and kind of group them up
so we group them up into compute
optimize memory optimized accelerator
optimized and then general purpose
so
the the compute ones are for
you know where you need the lowest
latency single threaded computation
possible memory is where you need the
maximum memory you can possibly stuff in
a in a machine you know you're running
like an in-memory database or something
and the accelerator ones are for when
you need a gpu or you know one of our
tensor processing units
and then for everything else general
purpose general purpose just like most
people just need a laptop like so okay
you have these specific uh groupings
maybe families of machines ordered
within those families can i can i
specialize like if i need a high-end
gaming laptop versus just like a low-end
gaming laptop absolutely um and you know
the first knob you have is just how big
it is you know so how many cpus and
memory so you can have like a two core
machine or a 20 or a 460 you know core
machine you know um and so they get it
bigger and smaller yeah really
and and you know up to 12 terabytes of
memory right now and like those numbers
keep getting bigger over time so depend
you know when you see this it might be
different um
and
you know by default those come in kind
of like a preset ratio so they kind of
grow together um but the
you know kind of part of the main reason
people wanted to use containers at all
is that not everything fits in that
exact shape so you end up kind of
orphaning some of the capacity and
you're kind of wasting money so we also
allow you with the general purpose
machines to pick
um your own ratio so if you're like oh i
know this is a really cpu heavy thing
but i don't need that much memory you
can make a computer that's that shape
and you only pay for what you actually
need
oh that's really cool okay so
these like if you can make your own
shape somewhere there has to be physical
memory uh so where do we get this in a
cloud vm yep so when you turn when you
go to set one of these up you know we
find one of the machines out there that
has space for the shape you want and
start it up there and so that's you know
this um kind of a tetris problem becomes
not your problem and we're big enough
that there's almost always a good spot
for that to fit
yeah and so these
are all on one machine it just sounded
like there oh so you know there's a data
center worth of machines and so like
when you go to start yours up you know
we find the right spot for it you know
find a computer that has open space so
tell me a little bit more about disk
then in this in this slice of a data
center world so if we can just turn it
on on like any one of these computers in
a data center right like how do the
disks work um where's my data um and so
we by default our disks are almost
always network attached storage and so
instead of a a physical disk plugged
into one computer i mean those still
exist but we provide a virtual disk made
up of hundreds or thousands of disks
plugged into a whole bunch of computers
and then assemble you know the blocks
together virtually
um
which gives you
um you actually get higher performance
than you might get normally so like the
the throughput is very fast and then you
get a bunch of the features that you
might expect from like a sand like a
storage area network
so you're gonna you can attach and
detach on the fly you can
yep okay that's really cool so you can
do that you can resize it um
and like
you use the snapshots to take backups
but the resize thing is kind of amazing
like if you run out of disk space you
can actually make the disk bigger while
the computer's running
ryan you're blowing my mind right now i
gotta i gotta act skeptical i'm gonna be
skeptical
you're blowing my mind
um something i'm curious about when i
when i'm using containers i can select
an operating system um and so what what
the benefit of that is i can write
applications to operating systems that i
know and love i can only use what i need
um is there that same concept in the vm
world or am i stuck like what am i
forced to use certain types of operating
systems to use a cloud vm yeah very
similar concept um you know with you
know whereas in a container it's mostly
just the files that make up that that
system you know kind of per per run time
whereas here we have the whole operating
system running um but other than that
it's really pretty much the same concept
you have
most workloads these days are running on
linux or windows and so we provide kind
of
pre-made images of debian centos core os
ubuntu red hat enterprise susie um and
windows server data center a bunch of
different versions
um so when you create a vm you say okay
i wanted to run this os and and it
makes a copy of that image you know kind
of on the fly and boots your machine off
of that okay that's really cool um are
you can you use your own at all yeah so
if you uh two ways to do it so one if
you want to use one of these os's and
just kind of
put your flavor on it add some tools
configure it the way you want it to be
you can boot off of one of them and then
make a new image based off of the work
you did nice so that that's a really
common thing and then if you if you want
to it's a block device and so you know
you can
you know make a customized version of an
os or you know develop a whole new os
and as long as that runs in a virtual
machine
you can boot off of it and go
i gotta be honest it sounded like
there's a lot of flexibility there like
all these things like well in containers
you can do this you're like yes you can
do this in vmworld too well and a lot of
it's based on so like this is a you know
kind of a you know high level version of
what a cloud vm is you can basically run
anything that runs on a computer
um
okay so i all right we just specified
really quick there's some virtual parts
or some physical parts uh your discs are
going to be spread out over the uh over
a wide data center pull it together to
give you more reliability uh more
consistency a lot of times you said it's
even faster throughput
this is like really cool what i'm
curious about is uh what are like actual
like things that are non-obvious
extensions of this that like what can i
do with this like yeah
i think one of the
you know like underused or kind of
unknown things is actually running a
container like a kind of one one
container per vm
as a pattern
yeah why would i why would i do that
so a couple of different reasons like
one containers have become kind of a
distribution format so a lot of software
is already you know ready to go
in a container um and sometimes
you know you don't want to
deal with kind of setting up a whole
cluster or managing some other stuff you
just want to run one thing so that's
that's a reason to do it and then
sometimes there's you know constraints
like that particular thing
it might make sense to run it on a very
large machine for a short amount of time
or
you know it needs you know some
particular like
uh configuration that you might not have
otherwise right so
it makes sense to kind of run of
containers yeah one to one
okay that makes a lot of sense uh what
all right but i i mean in theory i could
still run containers for a lot of this
what are some other features of cloud
vms that you're excited about yeah so um
one i think is
um
it's really commonly used in almost all
architectures you know pretty much
everybody has a load balancer when you
have multiple machines right
and the
the non-obvious like cool thing is that
yes we have a load balancer but it's a
load balancer service that is provided
at the data center level
it's not you know some particular
computer that has a certain capacity
that as soon as you hit like things
start slowing down or getting you know
overdrawn so you're actually configuring
the data center level load balancer
that google uses for like youtube and
gmail to run your own
machines
that's
so i one that's just really cool
thinking about that concept but what i'm
blown away right now is thinking in uh
kubernetes uh i use services all the
time yep and this and gke this uh the
load balancer that's provided is the
cloud load balancer the google one so
even then i'm using the google cloud
load balancer um
my question though is like i can still
access this load balancer it sounds like
it's configured already for me through
something like kubernetes um is there a
reason to go lower is there a reason to
go to to this level so if you're already
using kubernetes you know use kubernetes
but i think um you know it's those
patterns
are super useful and you know not all
software you know is set up to run in
containers or is so easy to do there
so if you want to use those things
having
a single endpoint that you can
communicate with yeah so this idea of
having a known endpoint that you know
provides this service and then there's a
group of you know containers usually in
kubernetes but a group of computers in
this case
that you know do that and
once you do that you have um a known
endpoint and a group of computers and we
call that group in compute engine a
manage instance group
then you can put a bunch of logic on
that so it's actually a service in and
of itself so it handles starting up new
machines when they're needed if you turn
the dial up and you're like oh i have
five now and i want to have ten it
starts the new ones um that can be set
up to be run automatically you know
depending on the load you get
and then
you can spread those out across the
world you can you know have some of them
running in one country some of them
running somewhere else and route the
traffic to the closest one for your
users that sort of thing
i'm gonna have to find out more about
this like i'm i'm gonna have to dig in
deeper because like i wanna be skeptical
and i'm like this all sounds amazing um
in a further i i think like i don't want
this conversation to go too long but i'm
definitely going to want to dig in
deeper
here
um
in fact maybe maybe we can have an
outfit so this would you count this as a
like admin infrastructure networking
what is yeah i think i think we should
dive into the networking a bit more next
right and kind of how that actually
works and
you know when i say it's not running on
one box
wait what how do you how do you
distribute traffic if it's not going
through one machine so let's do
networking and then i'm just you know i
love the discs and there's a lot more to
talk about there let's do that what else
do you want to hear about this for sure
i want to hear about cost uh i'm gonna
have to do some my own homework after
hearing about like machine families and
uh all of this i need to go start and
create a vm and i hope people listening
at home do the same thing yes because
because
i'm i'm gonna be more skeptical next
episode okay i'm going deeper but this
episode
i gotta admit cloud vms sound pretty
cool they are give it a try
alright well thank you brian and i'll
catch up with you next time see you soon
[Music]
you